now Microsoft's fake news watchdog
called news guard has turned its
attention to the UK it's now labeled the
as trustworthy three tabloid newspapers
the son the Daily Mirror and also The
Daily Star and that's not the only
decision of the so-called blacklister
that has been called into question as
Donald quarter reports remember news
guard that handy dandy Microsoft program
that tells you what is and isn't fake
news well they're still hard at work
putting little green check marks next to
information they like in search engines
news guards co-founder calls it applying
a little common sense to searching
information we're going to apply common
sense to a problem that the algorithms
haven't been able to solve we're gonna
hire a dozens of journalists to read and
review the seventy five hundred news and
information sites common sense might not
be enough if the admins are living under
a rock though Robert Muller's report is
out and many liberal tall tales about
Trump Russia collusion have been
debunked still a lot of those stories
are marked with a big friendly check
mark Trump sharing polling data with the
Russians check except it's not true
Muller subpoenaing bank records check
but same thing not true Trump's lawyer
secretly meeting with a Kremlin official
in Prague
well at least they changed the article a
bit still a big check even though the
title isn't exactly true in fact the
check marks don't even have to do with
how wrong the story is if news guard
trusts the outlet they're good to go our
green-red rating signal if a website is
trying to get it right or instead has a
hidden agenda or knowingly publishes
falsehoods or propaganda so I guess the
takeaway from that is that outlets like
the New York Times and BuzzFeed's don't
really have hidden agendas and if that
sounds ridiculous to you don't worry
news guard will make sure you know right
from wrong soon enough what's
interesting to note is their reaction to
this they're saying we are not
necessarily acknowledging or passing
judgment on the verrat
and accuracy of the information we're
just passing judgment on these source of
it these people this source this group
this website this newspaper this
whatever we give them our check mark we
approve of them what they say wow we
don't really necessarily pass judgment
on that if you go down the list of all
of those items which have passed
editorial muster it's the same it's
breathtakingly obvious to anybody that
if your story or if your source repeats
this meme this trope that there was
Russian collusion obstruction of justice
anything negative to trump it will be
checked and approved without any problem
not misleading trustworthy verifiable
job well done
you